[Music]
people are looking at me funny good
morning Hank it's Monday I'm going to
give you two clues to my location and
then you're going to have to guess it in
number one every time any one of those
pretzels I'm like this is what dog
biscuits taste like two dogs and hint
number two that's right Hank I'm in
yesterday's airport of yesterday the
Indianapolis International Airport I
don't know why they call it
International maybe they think
Wisconsin's a foreign country Hank a lot
of people concluded from one of my
videos last week that I was finished
with Paper Towns which is tragically not
the case in point of fact there's still
about six months left of work to do on
it but I'm only seven days away from
turning in what is hopefully going to be
the biggest revision to the book after
that I thought I would show it to you
and Katherine to see what y'all think
Hank I always like to spend the last
week before I turn in a revision in a
quiet place where I can do nothing but
think about and work on the book so this
time I'm going to Orlando Florida our
old stomping grounds because that's
where the book is primarily set but
aside from driving around and making
sure that Winter Park High School still
looks like Winter Park High School I'm
not going to be doing anything other
than working on the book that means that
I'm not going to have a lot of time for
Brotherhood 2.0 videos but some
nerdfighters made a suggestion that I
really really like which is that maybe
on Wednesday and Friday I can read you
some excerpts from Paper Towns this
would be helpful to me because it would
be nice to get some feedback while I'm
still working anyway Hank I hope that's
okay with you
hey Hank do you see that guy over in the
corner on the left I think that guy's my
pilot and he is really really really
good at MS pacman he's so good at miss
pac-man that he actually got to the part
where after 65 years of marriage miss
pac-man goes to mr. pac-man's funeral
she cried delicious little dots anybody
miss pac-man jokes no too old for the
audience okay Hank because I'm going to
Orlando to work on Paper Towns I'm
traveling pretty light I've got nothing
but a change of clothes a computer and
my old friend Walt Whitman all right
Hank we're going to close it out with
some poetry have you practiced so long
to learn to read have you felt so proud
to get to the meanings of poems stop
this day and night with me and you shall
possess the origin of all poems you
shall possess the good of the earth and
the Sun there are millions of Suns left
you shall no longer take things at
second or third-hand nor look through
the eyes of the dead nor feed on the
specters in books actually I really need
everybody to keep feeding on the
specters and books or else I'm out of a
job all goes onward now
or did nothing collapses I'll see you
tomorrow